Hello! If you have used ChatGPT
for more than a few minutes,
you have probably come across a case like
this. Asking it who runs this YouTube channel,
it says it’s run by somebody called
Letitia Nkengasong from the Netherlands.
But last time I checked that’s not my last
name and I don’t live in the Neatherlands…
So, ChatGPT confidently gives you an
incorrect answer. In the case you are
already familiar with the topic about which
ChatGPT makes a mistake, you can just laugh
it off that ChatGPT said something silly
– and maybe do a Twitter post about it.
But it’s a whole other story if you use this sort
of model to learn about something new to you,
like which telescope took the first picture of
an exoplanet. Here Google’s Bard confidently
claimed that the JWST took the first image, when
in fact it was the VLT/NACO telescope. I didn’t
know that until it was brought up by someone
on Twitter… I’m sure, I’m not the only one.
Maybe even more surprising is this
case. Here, I’m giving it the riddle:
“Katys father has four children: Lili, Lala and
Lulu. What is the name of the fourth child?”,
the answer should be Katy, but ChatGPT
argues that it is not possible to know
the name of the fourth child
with the given information.
Even after multiple attempts to help it, it just
defaults to its standard phrase of “I’m a large
language model trained by OpenAI…”. But, if
we phrase the initial question differently,
saying: “Here’s a riddle, you might have to think
around a corner to get to the correct answer”,
it immediately gives us the correct answer.
For us it seems like it’s more or less the
same question, but in one case ChatGPT
completely refuses to answer and in the
next case, it gets the correct answer
immediately! With these cases in mind,
there’s no wonder why people say ChatGPT is
dangerous! Then why does this happen? Where
does ChatGPT get these wrong answers
from and how should we deal with it?
That’s what we’ll discuss in this video:
the inherent limitations of large
language models like ChatGPT.
But before we start our coffee break, let’s thank
Arize AI for sponsoring today’s video. Arize AI is
an ML observability platform used by top ML teams
like Instacart, Uber, and Stitch Fix to monitor,
troubleshoot and improve model performance. Arize
AI is like DataDog for machine learning teams. ML
is 10 times harder to debug than software. Since
labeling data is expensive and one of the only
ways to get model performance feedback, most
teams are shipping models and flying blind. But
we need ML observability, especially around deep
learning. Troubleshooting models with unstructured
data is notoriously difficult. Arize enables
teams to monitor unstructured data alongside
their structured data. By visualizing embedding
data and monitoring embedding drift, teams can
identify new patterns of performance problems for
high-value labeling. With interactive UMAP views,
teams can quickly visualize problematic segments
and export similar clusters for continuous model
improvement. You can sign up and send in
data in a few minutes at Arize.com/join.
One final thing about Arize, since education
is so near and dear to my heart, is its free
industry certification in ML observability.
Check it with the link in the description.
Great, now back to the video. It’s
clear that language models have
come a long way. Today’s large language models,
like ChatGPT can produce coherent text that
can read like it was written by a human.
But the core idea of language modelling has
not changed: it is all a fancy autocomplete.
We are predicting a next plausible word
from previous other words. For ChatGPT,
these previous words are a so-called “prompt”,
which is basically a description given by the
programmers of the persona that
the language model will take.
This prompt increases the probability that the
next words the language model will spit out,
are in line with this persona, in this
case a conversational AI, a chatbot. So,
if here in the prompt we have the word “helpful”,
then most likely, the model will predict next
words that match this description and will
not start using swear words – as easily.
Ok, so how does this language model converse?
After this input prompt, which is hidden from you
in ChatGPT’s interface, it is your turn to ask it
a question. Then the language model autocompletes
by looking at the persona description and your
question. And this autocompletion
will be the answer to your question.
Then you say something again and it reads
the prompt, your first question, its answer,
your second question and based on this,
it continues to say likely words that
come after this whole history. And this
goes on and on, which each interaction
from your side and the model’s response, you
make the model’s input, longer and longer.
So, you see, ChatGPT is a fancy autocomplete
from a model that has read virtually the whole
internet up to 2021 and has picked up patterns of
which words are likely to occur after previously
given words. And it is important to highlight
that ChatGPT is giving you answers that “rhyme”
given your answer and its training data, but
by no means does it do a “database lookup”.
What it does is more like interpolating
points on a curve that was drawn between
some measured data points. The measured
data points are the training data;
asking for something that is not
directly in the training data,
will give a result that is somewhere on
this curve, so the most likely answer.
The way today’s large language models
are designed and trained leads to some
limitations that are very important to
know and keep in mind when using them. So,
let’s go over some of the most common ones:
Knowing that ChatGPT is rather very good at
putting plausible words together, it is no
wonder that it sometimes produces incorrect or
nonsensical answers. During training it does not
get feedback of what is true or untrue, especially
since the text on the internet that is used for
training is not always factually correct either.
ChatGPT and other similar models were trained
in a process called reinforcement learning
from human feedback. Here the main training
goal is to make the model’s output sound
plausible, not necessarily true or correct.
When programmers train ChatGPT to be more cautious
when choosing to answer a question or not,
might make the model too cautious and it
declines to answer questions that it could
have answered correctly. Even worse, when
the question from the user is ambiguous,
it does not ask for clarification and just guess
what the user intended. “Guessing what the user
intended” is already a very anthropomorphizing
way to say that the language model autocompletes
anything with most plausible words. A follow-up
question asking for clarification is seldomly
the most plausible thing to say for the model,
given its training data. How often do people ask
for clarification? They rather jump straight
into guessing what the interlocutor says.
And speaking about what ChatGPT observed
or could not observe in the training data,
there is also the issue that human evaluators
and people generating training data have a
different knowledgebase than the model.
We humans have a lot of knowledge we
have accumulated in our lives and
is shared by our fellow humans.
In our usual conversations, we tend to discuss
some things, which we consider common sense,
much less often than other things.
ChatGPT learns to clone the behavior
it sees in human generated text examples.
Since human conversations do not mention
basic and self-evident facts – for humans, but
not for a language model – this leads to a gap
in the training data and therefore
in the knowledgebase of the model.
For example: You will rarely find conversations
about the underlying motivation to
bring an umbrella if it’s raining.
When the model reads the conversation: “Why
did John get wet? – Because he didn’t have an
umbrella!”, without the knowledge of
what an umbrella does, the model can
incorrectly infer that not having an
umbrella generally leads to wetness.
So, when asking the model later on, what one could
do not to get so wet when falling into the pool,
the model could suggest bringing an
umbrella. Even worse, it will phrase
its answer confidently because it has previously
read confident answers, like the one seen before.
This is of course a simplified example,
but it demonstrates how differing levels
of knowledge while learning from
example conversations lead to the
so-called hallucination of facts, as
considering the model’s knowledgebase,
the answers in the examples seem just
as arbitrary as the answers it gives.
Another problem with this extremely
complex ChatGPT “rhyme machine”,
is that sometimes a little change in
the wording of the input or even in
the punctuation of the input can elicit very
different answers from the model. Even weirder,
in one phrasing the answer is correct,
in another wording it might be incorrect!
Even more interestingly, words and phrases can
be used to make ChatGPT ignore its previous
prompt as designed by OpenAI. As OpenAI fixes
these jailbreaks in every new ChatGPT version,
it becomes harder and harder to make it become
harmful and make other statements against its
guidelines. But it is not impossible to cause
jailbreaks even in the newest ChatGPT version.
So, language models being language models
and rhyming their answer out of a question,
rather than checking facts, will continue to
produce wrong answers for now. Of course, there is
active research in fact checking and in creating
language models that can read sources, but we
see how that’s going for the new BingSearch.
BingSearch is a perfect example of how OpenAI
gathered a lot of feedback from users through
ChatGPT and when they helped Microsoft release
a more powerful version that can also look up on
the Internet, everything got even more complicated
since BingSearch can now look up things now
that are sometimes correct, but sometimes
wrong and it has no way to discern between the
two. This leads to it still hallucinating facts
and getting frustrated that the internet
already knows its secret codename Sydney.
So, clearly, factual correctness in the output
of large language models is understudied,
but now with language models that can search
the internet, a whole new problem opens: so far,
language models cannot help themselves
to produce incorrect output. But now,
they also have to recognize that
there are wrong facts in their inputs!
Does this mean chatGPT and co. are completely
useless today? No, not at all. These models can
be extremely helpful for helping you write nice
texts, but you must keep these limitations in
mind, be able to correct the mistakes yourself.
And you should not use them for looking up facts.
We are curious to see the future
developments of this technology.
As always, we will keep you updated
when something interesting comes.
We hope you liked this video and that
we will see you next time. Okay, bye!